hello everyone i am and welcome to
simply learn today we will take you
through the hands of lab demo of how you
can implement loan approval prediction
using python
before we start i hope the screen is
clearly visible and the audio is fine if
yes please type in yes if there are any
issues do let us know in the chat
section so that we can resolve them
i'm repeating again before we start i
hope the screen is clearly visible and
the audio is fine if yes please type in
yes if there are any issues do let us
know in the chat section so that we can
resolve them
let's wait for some more minutes to let
the people join
until then let me tell you guys that we
have regular updates on multiple
technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and press that bell icon to
never miss any update from simply learn
i'm repeating again let me tell you guys
that we have regular updates on multiple
technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for the latest
technological trends then consider
getting subscribed to our youtube
channel and press that bell icon to
never miss any update from simply learn
great i think we can get started
in today's session we will go through
what is loan prediction system after
that we will move on to the hands of
live demo to perform loan approvals
prediction system moving forward we will
be using different classification
algorithms to implement loan approval
prediction system
we already have a loan approval data
with us we will perform different
function and libraries using python
you can download this dataset from the
description box below
before we move on to the programming
part let's discuss what is loan
prediction system first and proceed
further for the same a mechanism called
loan prediction system gives you a way
to apply for loans and receive
notification when they are approved in
accordance with the data provided by the
applicant the system notifies the
applicant of the loans available so here
is one question for you guys i will give
you one minute for this you can comment
or you can give your answer in the chat
section so i can see if the answer given
by you are right or wrong
i'm repeating again so here is one
question for you i will give you one
minute for this you can comment or you
can give your answer in the chat section
so i can see if the answers given by you
are right or wrong so the question is
which keyword is used for function in
python language
option one python
option two df
ocean c func
option d defined
so let us know your answer in the
comment section below
okay
so i am starting off timer one minutes
type your answer in the comment section
or in the chat section
do let me know your answers please i
currently ask that everyone take part in
this to make this live session exciting
so i'm starting the timer of one minute
which keyword is used for function in
python language
option one function
option two def
option c
punk option d define
each keyword is used for function in
python language
47k remaining
30 seconds let us know your answer in
the comment section below
this is the easy one which keyword is
used for function in python language
function dev
funk or define
i currently ask that everyone take part
in this to make this
exciting
a second more
after that a lot of time has passed
those who provided the correct response
will receive a response and those who
provided the incorrect response will
receives one
so
now let's move to our programming part
to implement loan approval prediction
system
so first we will open a command prompt
to write a command to open jupyter
notebook so here we will write jupyter
notebook
press enter
so this is the landing page of jupiter
notebook and here you have to select new
python3 file
so this is how the jupyter notebook ui
looks like
so at first we will import some major
libraries of python which will help us
creating a loan approval prediction
system
so
here i will write
import
numpy
as
np
so numpy is a python library used for
working with arrays it also has a
function for working in domain of linear
algebra and matrices
it is an open source project and you can
use it freely numpy stands for numerical
python
and the second one is
port
pandas
as pd panda is a software library
written for the python programming
language for data manipulation and
analysis
in particular it offers data structure
and operations for manipulating
numerical tables and time series
and the third one is
important
dot pi plot
as plt
so matplotlib python scripts can be used
to create 2d graphs and plots using the
matplotlib pi module with features to
control line styles font attributes
formatting access and other features it
offers a module called pi plot that
makes things simple for plotting
so the fourth one is
import
c bond
as
sns
so cbon an open source python library
based on matplotlib is called cbon it is
utilized for data exploration and data
visualization with data frames and the
pandas library c1 function with ease
so there is one more
like from
sklearn
port
svm
so after importing libraries let's move
forward and import data set
so
df equals to
pd dot read
underscore csv
phone
dot csv
you can download this data set from the
description box below
so yeah
so data set is imported let's see our
data set so we will write df dot head
yeah
yeah
here you can see
we have data set
of top five rows so basically head is
used for showing first five rows of the
data set
if we will use tail instead of head so
it will show the last five rows of the
data set
so let's move forward and use
info function to see the information
about the data set
okay so here we will write
df dot info
so the data front information is printed
by the info method
the data includes the total number of
columns their labels data kinds memory
use range index and the number of cells
in each column that is non-null values
note that the info method does indeed
print the information
okay so here you can see loan id is
object
then this applicant income is n64
then co-applicant income is float
so no null values like this
so
we know all the column names data types
and information let's move forward and
see missing values in the data set so
for that we will use here i will write
df dot is null
then basis
dot sum
yeah is nulls dot sum the data set total
number of missing values is returned via
sum
escape rows in the data set that have
missing values as a straightforward
solution for the missing value data
so we have missing values in loan id is
0 gender is 13
then loan amount is 22 self-employed is
32
so i hope you guys understand till here
if you have any questions or any query
regarding any code
so just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
i'm repeating again i hope you guys
understand till here if you have any
questions or any query regarding any
code or any question related to python
just put as in comments our team will
shortly provide you the correct solution
moving forward we will create one more
column
that is loan amount log
using loan amount detail and then we
will display a histogram for that okay
so let me do first
for the better view i can do this
yeah
i will write here df
don't
amount
let's go log
yeah
what's your nb
dot log
now we will do df
loan
amount underscore log
dot
hist
for the histogram then pins i will take
20.
numpy.log
a mathematical function that helps user
to calculate natural logarithms of x
where x belongs to all the input array
elements you can see histograms it's
looking fine
let's see the null values in our new
column
so
i will write here
pf
dot is null
or some
so here you can see in loan amount log
there are 22 missing values
so moving forward let's create one more
column name total income in this we will
add two columns applicant income and
co-applicant income and we will display
histogram for the same
ef
like
total income
equals to df
applicant income
and we will add one more data from df
that is
co-applicant
f
total income
underscore log
also np dot
log
df
tf
well income
underscore log
dot hist
pins equals to 20.
yeah
so here you can see
histogram of that total income log
moving forward let's fill those null
values in all the respective columns
so here for that we will write
df
gender
dot fill n a
df
gender
dot mode
zero
comma
in place
question true
and
what i will do i will copy from here
change here
gender to
married
they're also married
and here
or self
employed
here i will do self
employed
to for
dependent
just everything will be same so here i
will add df dot
loan amount
was two
df dot
loan amount
dot fill n a
pf
dot
loan
amount
dot mean
so here i will write instead of this i
will copy from here
and paste it here
yeah
it's good log
l is small
so here i will write again that we can
take it from here
change column name
to loan
mount
on
amount
edit underscore
history
again
credit underscore
history
so here i will write
df
dot
is null
sum
okay it's
it's worth giving error
sam
self employed
okay what the issue is that is capital
in
dependent
okay
okay it's dependence
okay
yeah
so there is no missing values now
we're gonna do is we will select some
specific columns and rows for the
training and testing
so for that i will write here
x equals two
dot i lock
dot
r
in colon 11
comma 13 colon 15.
dot
values
y equals to
df dot
i lock
then colon comma 12
dot values
let me see the x values
okay so male know these are the x values
and
let me see the y values
okay so the iloc function in python is
defined in the pandas module that helps
us to select a specific row or column
from the dataset using the ilock method
in python we can easily retrieve any
particular value from a row or column by
using index values
so moving forward let's see the
percentage of missing genders from the
data set and we will do it for many
other columns
okay
so it if it will be zero so it will be
great for us so we will write
print
percent
of
missing gender
yes
percent
to
f
sin
and
we will write this
tf
in gender column
dot is null
dot sum
f
dot shape
zero
multiply by 100
saying function object has no attribute
sum
okay
why because
so percent of missing gender is zero
great
so like so moving forward we will see
number of people who take loan as a
group by gender
okay so for that we will write print
numbers
like of people
who take
loan
as
group
by
gender
for that
print
df
sender
dot value
value
counts
sentence dot
count
plot
x equals to
sender
set one
you can use either set to either set
three
so
let me see okay
so
here you can see like male is
five zero two female are one one
you can see the bar plot so the number
of observation in each category bins are
displayed using bars
using the count plot technique the
following parameters are accepted by the
procedure and are listed below this
parameter accept optional variable names
for data or vector data inputs for long
form data plotting so moving forward we
will do for the same
like number of people who take a loan
group by
medical status
so what i will do i will just copy from
here
and i will change it to here
so i will write
metal
latest and the guys who are married
here i have to write the
eight
so here you can see
like four zero one
are yes like and two one three are no
okay
so moving forward we will see number of
people who attain
loan group by dependents
so same what i will do i will paste it
here
i will just change the name here
dependent
change it to here
so here you can see the dependence and
the y label is the count
so like 0 or 360 102 101 and 51
and many more so moving forward we will
see number of people who take loan group
as a self-employed
okay
for that what we have to do is
we have to just change names
he is capital
here okay let's see the graph
so moving forward we will see number of
people who take loan group by loan
amount
for that i have to write here
it let me make a better visibility
yeah so
as a loan amount
don't
amount
capital
yeah
here you can see
bar graph
so at the end we will see the number of
people who take loan group by credit
history
okay so i will write here
same
as the
credit history
card is history
three
edit underscore
history
okay
yeah so here you can see 525
and this 89
so based on my assessment we don't have
any missing values in the data set now
so moving forward let's import
scikit-learn library for training and
testing dataset
so here i will write
from
sklearn dot model
model
underscore
selection
port
train
underscore test
underscore split
so i have like
train
comma
x
test
comma y
train
comma
y test
okay
so here i will write
train
underscore test underscore split
x comma y
comma
test
underscore size
equals to 0.2
random
state
equals to
zero
on
sk ascii learn
dot pre
processing
processing
import
label
encoder
okay
so label
score x
goes to
label
encoder
sk learn
my bad
x is not defined
here we have
psychic learn or escalant is the one of
the most robust library for machine
learning
it is open source and built upon numpy
scipy and matplotlib it provides a range
of tools of machine learning and
statical modeling
and train test split function of this
sqlearn model selection package in
python splits arrays or matrices into
random subsets for train and test data
and label encoder encode label with a
value between 0 and n classes minus 1
where n is the number of distinct label
moving forward let's fit and transfer
data for training
so here we will write for
i in
i in range
0 comma
5
x underscore train
fit
transform
and x underscore train
colon comma i
and x underscore train
seven
equals to
order
underscore x
dot fit
transform
underscore train
let's see
x underscore
oh sorry
let's go
train
and yeah this i
this is capital x
weight transform joins these two steps
and is used for the initial fitting of
the parameter on the trading set
while also returning the transform x
internally the transfer object just
calls first fit and then transform on
the same data
and we will
perform same for the y
so
i have i will write here
table
encoder unesco y
label
label
encoder
okay
i underscore train
equation
label
encoder
underscore y dot
fit
let's go
transform
you see the results
yeah
so training of the data set is done
let's do for same for the testing data
so i will write here for
i in
range
0
comma 5
underscore test
i
equals to
label
order
underscore x
dot
fit
underscore
transform
underscore
test
of i
then again
x underscore test
column comma 7
equals to
label
encoder
underscore
dot
fit
underscore transform
underscore
test
then colon comma 7
yeah
and see the results x underscore test
okay it seems good
all the values
so we will do for the same
y test
so we will write here label
encoder
let me put
let's go y
question level
order
so why underscore test equals to
test
just let's see
okay
moving forward we will import a standard
scalar for the further process
so for that we will write here
from sklen
dot pre-processing
port
[Music]
assign this standard
i will do i will copy it from here
so x train
equals to ss dot fifth
underscore transform
x underscore
train
then x underscore test
equals to ss dot
bit
underscore transform
underscore test
ok skill
dot pre-processing
okay
escalante processing
standard scalar
okay sorry
and again
like standard okay
er
yeah so standard scalar removes the mean
and scales each feature variable to unit
variance
this operation is performed feature-wise
in an independent way everything is done
let's see which classifier is best for
prediction by seeing their accuracy
so for that
i will write here
let me do one thing
yeah
so like i will write from
elearn
dot ensemble
symbol yeah
import
random
forest
classifier
so i will write if under
class clf classifier
equals to
random forest
sorry my bad
so rf
underscore clf
dot fit
x underscore train
comma y underscore train
fine
so i will write here from
sklearn
import
matrix
y underscore prediction
equals to rf underscore
classifier
dot predict
dot predict
x underscore test
so here i will print
accuracy
of random
random
forest
classifier is
comma matrix
it dot accuracy
score score
then y
underscore prediction
comma
y underscore test
i underscore prediction
so
let's see the prediction
from the using random forest classifier
and the accuracy a random foreign is a
matter estimator that employs averaging
to increase predicted accuracy and
reduce overfitting
if boost type equals to true the size of
this sub sample is determined by the max
sample argument otherwise each tree is
constructed using the entire data set
so here you can see the accuracy is like
78 percent
and here prediction you can see
like here one denotes
that loan approved and zero means loan
will not approve
so
accuracy is quite less so let's see for
another classification methods nav base
so here i will write from
sklearn
port
gaussian
nb nav base
okay so nb classifier
equals
to gaussian
and b
e
underscore classifier
equals to
sorry dot fit
strain
comma y
train
oh
a naught equals two
oh like gaussian
okay g is capital
sorry
yeah
so
let's predict the value
by underscore predict
pursue nb
classifier
dot predict
x underscore
test
and print
accuracy
of
naive bayes
is
comma like matrix
dot accuracy
score score
y underscore prediction
comma y
underscore test
so accuracy of gaussian nb is
0.8 means 82 percent
let's predict the value by predict
prediction like one is like loan
approved and zero is loan or not
approved
so
nav base is a classification algorithm
for binary two classes and multi-classes
classification problem it is called name
based the calculation of the
probabilities for each class are
simplified to make that calculation
tractable
so the accuracy is 82 percent and here
prediction you can see one denotes loan
approved and 0 means loan will not
approve
so let's see for another classification
method like decision tree classifier
for that i will write here
from
sklearn
dot tree
import
port
decision
tree
classifier
here i will write dt underscore
classifier
first two
i will copy it from here
i will write here dt underscore clf
equals to
now so dot fit
x underscore train
comma y underscore train
why is small
so here i will
see the
accuracy
pursue dt
underscore classifier
dot predict
underscore
test
so here i will print
accuracy
of
decision tree
is
comma matrix
what accuracy
underscore
underscore predict
comma y underscore test
so here you can see the accuracy is 70
percent
so let me predict
so decision tree the non-parametric
supervised learning approach used for
classification and regression
application
it is organized hierarchically as and
has a note root branches internal nodes
and leaf nodes this so the accuracy is
70 and here prediction you can see one
denotes the loan approved
and 0 means
loan will not approve so let's do one
more classification we will do it from
the k numbers using k neighbors
over here we will write
from
dot
burst
import
k neighbors
classifier
kn classifiers
we will assign
this
so here we will write k and underscore
classifier
dot
fit
x under
strain comma y underscore chain
okay
sk learn
sorry
then again
okay
it's capital here
brittle here
yeah
it
yeah
so here i will see the accuracy
okay
my prediction equals to
kn
underscore classifier
dot
predict
x underscore test
print
accuracy
of
k neighbors is
matrix
dot accuracy
score score
y underscore prediction
comma y
underscore
test
so let's see the accuracy
so accuracy is 79 and it is quite good
so the k numbers the five closed
neighbors are sought for the k numbers
classifier the classifier must be
explicitly instructed to utilize
euclidean descent to determine the
proximity of nearby points
so the accuracy is 79 percent
and here prediction you can see one
denotes the loan approved and zero means
loan will not approve
so you can see
nav base
his name is yeah
so here you can see
we have name based classifier with the
best accuracy of 82 percent so we can
use it for the loan approval prediction
system
so i hope you guys understand till here
if you have any questions or any query
regarding any code just put as in
comments our team will shortly provide
you the correct solution
i hope you guys must have understood the
concept of how we can implement loan
approval prediction system using python
if you have any queries you can ask in
the comment section below our team will
shortly respond you as soon as possible
and if you want this full code
and if you you want this full code just
comment for the same thank you so much
for being here if you enjoyed this video
please do subscribe to our youtube
channel and give a like to this video
thank you and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here